in a city that loves its bikes there is
one man looking out for the rest
one man brave enough to bring bike
thieves to justice a man the city calls
bike batman in reality i'm just an
engineer
back in the early 2000s i started really
noticing you know there's a lot of bike
theft i remember i had a set of wheels
stolen i was livid i was super poor and
there was
nothing to do you know i couldn't
recover them it was so frustrating for
me knowing that the police are so busy
with so many other crimes in seattle
that there was nobody following up on
these minor incidents
enough was enough he realized he needed
to take the law into his own hands and
he had the perfect plan
i would best describe bike index as a
database
that allows you to register your bicycle
it's a great way to search for stolen
bikes
the way it works for me is as i'm
perusing craigslist i'll notice a fishy
ad and i will immediately open up bike
index and do a quick search
for any bikes that have been stolen in
that geographic area
the first time that i recovered a bike i
had no idea what i was doing i drove
after work to go meet this guy and it
wasn't one person i was meeting it was
three
and
i told him you know guys the cops were
on the way i just called him this bike
is stolen and you're not going to be
leaving with it eventually threw the
bike in my truck burned out returned the
bike it felt great what began as a
simple plan to help a fellow cyclist
took on a life of its own
seattle's own bike vigilante was born
we were able to recover
high 30s or low 40s of bikes
i'm not entirely sure when the bike
vigilante had become a thing it was
probably when the bike batman moniker
was given to me and this is just
something you know i like doing i don't
need or want you know any recognition
just doing good is essentially you know
how i try to live my life and thanks to
bike batman the cyclists of emerald city
can rest easy
once more
[Music]
you